We all know that it doesn't pay to gamble,
but a week ago, I heard a paradox that seems
to show the opposite- that you can earn money
whenever you gamble.
Let me show you how it works for a particular
game- but after I'll show you it generalises
to any.
The game I heard it in the context of is Roulette.
Apparently there's a way to play the game
where you just need to guess either black
or red- both have an equal probability.
You bet a certain amount of money and if you're
right, they give you the amount you betted.
If you lose, you pay them.
Simple.
So convince yourself that this is a game of
pure chance, if you played this game a lot
you wouldn't expect to win or lose anything.
By the way, if you played this in a real casino
the odds are slightly against you so that
they make money- but that doesn't make a big
difference to this paradox so let's look at
the fair game for now.
It seems like there is nothing you can do
to improve the chance you make money.
But let’s think about this strategy.
What if you said, I'll always bet red.
First time I'll bet 2.
If I win, I'll stop.
Otherwise I'll play again but this time I'll
bet 4.
And if I lose again I'll bet 8, etc, etc.
Then say you win on the 3rd round.
You win 8, which covers all your previous
loses.
The beauty of this is, you will win eventually,
and whenever that is, you win back everything
you lost and then some.
You might say, yeah but the amounts of money
you're betting every time get huge quickly.
And that's true.
But it's pretty unlikely you'll even lose
many times in a row.
The probability you'll lose 3 rounds is 1
in 8.
The idea behind this strategy is to chase
your losses- you know, that thing that people
tell you never to do.
If you lost 3 rounds then you've lost 2+4+8=14.
So you bet 2 higher than that total loss.
That means that if you win this round, you
get back everything you lose, and 2 more.
You can check this yourself but this works
for what ever round you finish up on, you
bet your total losses so far plus 2.
So whenever you play this game, as long as
you go through until you eventually win a
round, you always make 2.
But this seems like a contradiction- you aren't
supposed to consistently make money playing
this game.
You're supposed to break even.
It gets worse than that, because you can apply
this strategy to any betting situation, now
matter the odds.
You just bet a little bit more than all your
total losses so far...
But wait, before you bet on your house, you
can see that this is clearly stupid for most
betting situations.
Most of the time, bets are stacked well against
you.
Let's say you're playing a game where you
have a 1/10 chance of winning each bet -which
is not at all unrealistic.
Then the chance you'll lose even 12 games
in a row is still very high, about 30%.
But at that point you'll have to spend about
$8000 and still are likely to lose more.
So yeah, don't actually go do this in real
life please.
This stratergy doesn't actually work- it's
obvious why not when the odds are like this,
but when the odds are 50/50, like in the roulette
game, it's hard to see what the problem is.
That's where the paradox is.
I'm going to give you a week to see if you
can figure it out.
It took me a lot of frustrated hours with
a friend until we cracked it, but it was good
fun to think about which is why I wanted to
tell you guys.
It's a very interesting paradox.
And if you do figure it out, here are some
other variations you might try.
What if you decide not to be too greedy, and
you only bet your total loss plus 1 each time,
instead of 2?
Or what if you get super greedy, and you bet
your loss plus some growing amount?
In those two scenarios, see how quickly the
amount you bet grows, and what your expected
winnings are.
If you need some hints, I have some small
ones in the description.
Good luck.
Try it with a friend so you can discuss it-
I highly recommend it.
Oh and, promise me one thing- that you won't
go gamble this week.
Thank you.